[Music]
what do you want to do with me
oh
i want to show you off to my ex-wife
make really jealous
hello and welcome to a heartbreaking new
episode of rt essentials i'm naz perez
and we all know that the history of
filmmaking is filled with love stories
but we also know that love is
complicated which is why there are also
plenty of breakup stories out there as
well which if i'm being honest can
scratch us in a more familiar place than
classic love stories do because the
simple fact is almost all of us have
been dumb and whether you turn to
breakup movies to feel all the feels or
just to feel one particular feeling that
can only be repaired with a tub of ice
cream these films definitely serve a
major purpose in the world of cinema so
get your tissues ready because today we
are talking about the best breakup
movies of all time to laugh and ugly cry
to
forgetting sarah marshall you know how
we thought the killer
before he committed each homicide
that's the theory
take a look at the microscope
oh yeah
looks like where he's going
to know him
kicking things off with one that i'm
sure you remember in spite of its title
and that's 2008's forgetting sarah
marshall co-produced by judd avatau this
comedy was written by and stars jason
siegel who said that the film is based
on his experiences with multiple
breakups and yes that includes the
infamous nude breakup scenes in this
film he plays peter the boyfriend of big
shot tv star sarah marshall played by
kristen bell who unceremoniously dumps
him leaving his world shattered so peter
goes to hawaii by himself to try and get
over her and wouldn't you know it sarah
and her new boyfriend russell brands all
this snow just happened to be in hawaii
too at the same hotel in the room next
door and while he's there peter falls
for a hotel employee played by mila
kunis tossing a little drama into the
whole situation and while the big
breakup takes center stage in this movie
what really carries it is the ultra
funny cast which according to director
nicholas staller improvised 30 to 40
percent of the film's dialogue and while
romantic connections are made the real
chemistry here is between jason siegel
and paul rudd who would continue their
bromance the following year in i love
you man and kristen bell and mila kunis
two powerhouses in their own right
played great off of each other in this
film as well and they too joined forces
again in the bad moms franchise the
critics were all about the cast in this
one too with a consensus that quote
forgetting sarah marshall finds the
right mix of romantic and raunchy comedy
oh oh um
so that doesn't mean i have to leave the
hotel ken found you a room
i'll take it yeah i want to uh i want to
hang out with rachel a little more
are those sad tissues or happy tissues
um
maybe you should just give me a minute
and if five nominations that the 2018
choice awards tells you anything which
it shouldn't it's that this breakup
movie and your next friday night are the
perfect match legally blonde okay i'm
gonna show you a little maneuver that my
mother taught me in junior high
in my experience it has a 98 success
rate of getting a man's attention and
when used appropriately it has an 83
rate of return on a dinner invitation
wow
it's called the bend
and snap the next film on this list
might as well be filed under educational
because it's the perfect blueprint for
how to better yourself after a big
breakup i'm talking about legally blonde
reese witherspoon stars in this one as
fashion student and sorority girl l
woods and she's on the fast track to a
perfect life until her boyfriend who she
thinks is going to propose breaks up
with her instead he's headed to harvard
law school and route to a career in
politics and he doesn't think that she
is serious enough for a life like that
but in an effort to win him back elle
works her tail off and actually gets
into harvard law herself only to find
out that her ex has moved on to his old
girlfriend and all of elle's new east
coast classmates are not feeling her
socal vibes and her on point style and
speaking of style reese actually wrote
it into her contract that she got to
keep all of her outfits from filming so
smart the film was directed by robert
lucetic in his feature film debut and
it's based on amanda brown's 2001 novel
of the same name where the author
touches on her own experiences as a
blonde going to stanford law school
while being obsessed with fashion and
beauty after opening in theaters in july
of 2001 the movie became a huge hit to
the tune of over 140 million dollars on
an 18 million dollar budget and listen
i'm no math whiz but that usually means
sequels in hollywood and in this case
there was legally blonde 2 red white and
blonde in 2003 and there's now a third
legally blonde film officially in the
works with mindy kaling and dan gore
writing it which is due out in 2022 so
buckle up for more blonde i'm sorry
sorry for what for breaking my heart or
for giving me the greatest pleasure i've
ever known and then just
taking it away
uh
both
well forget it i've already spent too
many hours crying over you
so
when did you want to go out
reese witherspoon may have just missed
out on winning an mtv movie award for
her role in this film no thanks to
nicole kidman moulin rouge but the
consensus from critics is that reese
witherspoon's funny nuanced performance
makes this movie better than it would
have been otherwise
call me by your name trust me i'm about
to be a doctor
hey come here see that's the problem get
your stress you just gotta relax a
little bit i am relaxing
marcia come here for a minute
back to me up here
feel that right there
it's too tight right he needs to relax
later
you should relax more
if there's one thing you can call this
next film it would be award-winning or
certified fresh i know that's two things
but let's just move on it's 2017's call
me by your name this coming of age drama
was directed by luca guadagnino and is
set in northern italy in 1983 where a
romantic relationship forms between 17
year old elio and a 24 year old american
grad student named oliver now oliver is
living with elio's family for the summer
as he works under his father an
archaeology professor but as their
relationship grows stronger so does the
dreadful reality that oliver will be
heading back to america at the end of
the summer and of course heartbreak
ensues when he does go back and tears
were shed we're talking about me now i'm
a prior anyways this film actually wraps
up what is known as luca guadagnino's
desire trilogy after 2009's i am love
and 2015's bigger splash and the script
which was written by james ivory and
based on andre osimon's 2007 novel of
the same name brought home the oscar for
adapted screenplay and while the
sprawling 17th century property in
northern italy where filming took place
was definitely a star 22 year old
timothy chalamet became the third
youngest best actor nominee in oscar's
history for his performance plus he
learned a third language for this movie
i mean is there anything timothy can't
do the film itself was also nominated
for an academy award for best picture
but perhaps what's even more cool is
that a book was published in 2018 by a
fan named barb morell who collected
stories from fellow fans around the
world about what this film has meant to
them amazon it and critics fell in love
too with robert daniels from 812 film
reviews complementing the quote poignant
screenwriting keem directing and tender
um
with the critics consensus that this
film offers a melancholy powerfully
affecting portrait of first love high
fidelity
now the making of a good compilation
tape is a very subtle art many do's and
don'ts
first of all you're using someone else's
poetry to express how you feel this is a
delicate thing
so for this one i'm thinking
i'm thinking
what is this gonna stop it is time to
dust off the old vinyl collection for
this next breakup flick high fidelity
released in the year 2000 this film
stars john cusack as rob gordon a record
store owner who gets stumped by his
long-term girlfriend laura played by
even yahya so he starts seeking out past
partners to try and figure out why his
relationships keep failing besides the
fact that he owned a record store at a
time when cds were out i mean look it up
rob's journey to find answers and love
brought us some great performances from
stars like catherine zeta-jones lisa
bonet sarah gilbert and lily taylor and
when rob wasn't chasing love he was
watching his record store employees
played brilliantly by jack black and
todd luiso chase away customers this
while they argued over musical top five
lists for pretty much any and every
occasion that you can imagine the film
was directed by steven frears and based
on the 1995 british novel of the same
name by nick hornby with the setting
move from london to chicago and with
what has become a certified fresh cult
classic became a series adaptation 20
years after the film was released
starring zoe kravitz the daughter of
lisa bonang you love to see it the
consensus from critics on this one is
that strong performances by the ensemble
cast combine to tell an entertaining
story
i'm gonna talk to you about whether or
not
you want to get married
to me
i'm serious
yes i know thanks
i'm sorry
two days ago you were making tapes for
that girl from the reader yeah well
forgive me if i don't think of you as
the world's safest bet would you marry
me if i was
with steven ray from the philadelphia
inquirer calling high fidelity one long
hook-filled pop song for the eyes and
don't forget about the bruce springsteen
cameo
the first wives club i do have feelings
i'm an actress i have all of them well i
wouldn't understand you see i'm just a
portable housewife and a little apron
with a little child to raise yeah well
you were always jealous of me even in
college because i was blind and
beautiful and talented and i got any guy
i wanted and did every guy most of the
senior class and half the faculty well
it was the 60s if you were lucky enough
to be invited into this club in 1996 you
were hanging with hollywood royalty i'm
talking about the first wives club
directed by hugh wilson and based on
olivia goldsmith's 1992 novel of the
same name this film stars diane keaton
bette midler and goldie hawn as three
divorcees looking for payback against
their ex-husbands who have left them for
younger women and as if that wasn't
enough star power for you the young
lovers are played by sarah jessica
parker marcia gay hardin and elizabeth
berkley and by the way joining this
stacked cast was a handful of
wonderfully 90s cameos from people like
kathie lee gifford gloria steinem and
ivana trump you're welcome the story
unfolds as a middle-aged divorcee jumps
off a building after her ex marries a
younger woman and when her college
friends midler han and keaton come
together for her funeral they realize
how similar all of their divorce stories
are and they set out to get back at
their exes for taking them for granted
the film was considered a surprise box
office success after grossing more than
181 million dollars at the worldwide box
office and despite mixed reviews and a
rotten 49 on the tomato meter it has
since developed a cult following mostly
among middle-aged women it also marks
the three main actresses highest
grossing project of the 90s and as
critics have argued helped breathe new
life into some of their careers to go
along with the film's poor score from
critics is a consensus that quote the
script lets the trio of comedic dynamos
down with tepid plotting and a fatal
lack of satirical bite the actresses
though have showed interest in a sequel
over the years sparking plenty of rumors
in the meantime though there's a series
based on the film that premiered on
b-e-t plus in 2019. do it maurice do it
to me now
i need it
you're the only one who does it the way
i like it you're the king elise if i
give you any more collagen your lips are
gonna look like they got stuck in a pool
drain and of course they could always
bring back first wise club the musical
because i mean come on everything's
better is a musical 500 days of summer
we've been like sitting nancy for months
now summer sid stabbed nancy
seven times the kitchen i thought i mean
we'd have some disagreements but
i hardly think i'm sid vicious
no
i'm sid the next movie on this list
2009's 500 days of summer is another
great example of how music can perfectly
capture the highs and the lows of love
joseph gordon-levitt stars as a greeting
card writer named tom who is completely
caught off guard when his girlfriend
summer played by zoe deschanel suddenly
dumps him the film jumps around to
various moments as he reflects back on
their 500 days together as a couple this
was the feature film debut for director
mark webb who went on to helm both
amazing spider-man films but who is
mostly a music video director at the
time he described the film as more of a
coming-of-age story as opposed to a
rom-com while others just called it the
breakout indie hit of the summer in 2009
and i mean what a nice compliment the
film was set in san francisco for an
early draft of the screenplay before
eventually moving to los angeles which
definitely plays a role in the film
along with the soundtrack or should i
say soundtracks considering that two
were released for the film featuring
artists like the smiths the temper trap
regina spektor carla bruni wolf mother
zoe's group she and him and a few
classics for good measure like simon
garfunkel and hall of notes i mean
listen if they got an ampersand in their
name count me in you know what sucks
realizing that everything you believe in
is completely utter
sucks
what do you mean uh you know destiny and
soulmates
true love and all that childhood
fairy tale
nonsense you were right i should have
listened to you
no
yeah
what are you smiling at the critics were
rocking out to this one as well with a
consensus that this film is quote
refreshingly honest and utterly charming
with billy goody coons from the arizona
republic calling it an immensely
satisfying experience much like love
itself amen robert eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind it would be different
if we could just give it another go
round
[Music]
remember me
try your best
[Music]
maybe we can
[Music]
and bringing its own little ray of
something to this list of breakup movies
is 2004's eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind kate winslet stars in this
one as clementine who after a painful
breakup undergoes a procedure to erase
memories of her former boyfriend jim
carrey joel from her mind i mean if only
it were that easy right and when he
finds out about these extreme measures
she's taking to forget their
relationship joel undergoes the same
procedure and slowly starts to forget
the woman that he loves joining jim and
kate on this wild adventure is a stellar
ensemble cast that includes kirsten
duntz mark ruffalo elijah wood and tom
wilkinson it could have been even more
impressive because ellen pompeo and
tracy morgan were cast and even filmed
some stuff but their parts ultimately
got cut the film which gets its title
from a quote in an alexander pope poem
was directed by michelle gondry an
accomplished music video director at the
time and the script was written by
charlie kaufman writer of films like
adaptation and being john malkovich and
mixes some sci-fi elements with
psychological drama to explore the
nature of memory love and loss kaufman
took home the oscar for best original
screenplay while winslet was nominated
for best actress but lost to hilary
swank for a million dollar baby i mean
talk about a punch to the gut get it
because that movie was a boxing movie
anyways eternal sunshine has crept into
cult following territory over the years
and there have been rumors of a
potential television series based on the
film being in development for some time
now i'm lost i'm scared i feel like i'm
disappearing
my skin's coming off i'm getting old
nothing makes any sense to me you're not
getting old nothing makes any sense
nothing makes any sense
but what we can bank on is the fact that
critics love this certified fresh flick
with the consensus that kaufman's smart
imaginative script and gondry's equally
daring directorial touch makes this film
a twisty yet heartfelt look at
relationships and heartache
like crazy
time to rack up some frequent flyer
miles because the next film on this list
is all about long distance relationships
and that's 2011's like crazy the late
anton yelkin stars in this film is jacob
an american attending college in los
angeles who falls hard for anna a
student from london played by felicity
jones but after falling madly in love
the inseparable lovers are forced apart
when she has to return to england after
violating the terms of her visa so they
give the long distance relationship
thing a shot and learn just how hard it
can be especially mixed in with their
ever-changing lives jennifer lawrence
co-stars in this film as well as
samantha a girl who loves and dates
jacob on and off between his breakups
with anna director drake doremus
partially based the story on his own
long-distance relationship with a woman
in london while he lived in los angeles
but rather than writing a traditional
screenplay for the film he actually put
together a 50-page outline with
backstory plot points specific scene
objectives themes and emotional moments
and then let the actors improvise almost
all of the dialogue from there
impressive filming took place over 4
weeks in la and london on a budget of
just 250 000 which included the cost of
airfare for everyone to get over the
pond but despite all that the certified
fresh film premiered at the sundance
film festival where it won the grand
jury prize why can't you look at me and
tell me
look at me and don't shout i'll shout if
i want it no you won't shout you won't
chat in my house all right then we'll go
back to my house yeah i'd love to go
back to the overseas you have to go
right now why are you shouting them i
understand why you can say things like
that to me yes i'd rather be
there the critic's consensus for like
crazy is that it allows its characters
to express themselves beyond dialogue
crafting a true intimate study with
peter bradshaw from the guardian calling
it a grown-up love story ugh being a
grown-up isn't worse crazy stupid love
hi
who looks like a carrot
conan
o'brien my friend um
hannah here thinks he's sexy that's
weird because i think that your friend
hannah is really sexy oh my god
you did not just say that how old are
you
what are you lawyer
a little bit come on i know you want is
she gonna be don't you think you're a
little old to be using cheesy pickup
lines objection
leading the witness
get ready for another crazy breakup film
from 2011 because the next one on our
list is crazy stupid love this film star
steve carell is cal weaver a family man
who is living a dream life that checks
all the boxes he's got a good job a nice
house great children and a beautiful
wife named emily played by julian moore
but things start to get crazy and stupid
when cal finds out that emily has been
unfaithful and actually wants a divorce
and his life just starts to unravel
that's when ryan gosling's jacob
character who's a hit with the ladies
enters the picture and takes the over 40
and suddenly single cow under his wing
the pair hang out so cal can learn how
to navigate the fickle world of dating
and rounding out this impressive cast is
emma stone marissa tomei singer josh
groban in his feature film debut and
kevin bacon
thank you the film was directed by glenn
fakira and john requa who wrote 2003's
bad santa together and it was written by
dan fogelman who based the screenplay on
his own experiences while writing it
with steve carell in mind i mean i guess
that worked out they shot it over 53
days in and around los angeles and the
result was an original cut that was
actually three hours long i mean that's
a lot of crazy or was it stupid or was
it you get it
and while they managed to trim over an
hour off of the total run time the dirty
dancing style lift that ryan gosling and
emma stone managed to pull off still
made it into the film even though it
wasn't in the script and for that i say
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
sorry i'm gonna help myself it's like
one of my favorite lines ever
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
critics were feeling mostly love for
this film with the consensus that it's
unabashed sweetness and it's
terrifically talented cast more than
make up for its flaws marriage story
people don't accept mothers who drink
too much wine and yell at their child
and call them and
i get it i do it too
we can accept an imperfect dad let's
face it the idea of a good father was
only invented like 30 years ago
before that fathers were expected to be
silent and absent and unreliable and
selfish and we can all say we want them
to be different
but on some basic level we accept them
and finally we're not going to say that
the last film on this list is depressing
but it's not not depressing and that's
2019's marriage story this one stars
adam drivers charlie a theater director
in new york city who's producing a play
that stars his wife nicole a former teen
film actress played by scarlett
johansson
the couple is having marital issues and
is seeing a mediator and when nicole is
offered a starring role in a tv pilot in
los angeles
she decides to temporarily move there
and take their son henry along
now charlie stays in new york to focus
on his broadway-bound play creating a
coast-to-coast divorce situation and
despite agreeing to split amicably they
both end up hiring lawyers and things
start to get messy
the supporting cast is rounded out with
laura dern allen alda ray liotta julie
hagerty and merritt weaver with durhan's
character actually being loosely based
on la celebrity attorney laura wasser
who get this represented durn johansen
and writer director noah bombach during
their respective divorces in fact
mediation teams were filmed in wasser's
actual office building and speaking of
their respective divorces noah actually
based much of the film in large part on
his own experiences following his
divorce from actress jennifer jason lee
in 2013. he has said though that
jennifer read the script and has seen
the film and likes it
the film got some serious oscar love
with six nominations including best
picture best original screenplay best
actor and actress for driver johansen
and of course best supporting actress
for durn who actually took home the
hardware
it was the first netflix film to win an
academy award in an acting category and
history was made you're being so much
like your father
do not compare me to my father i didn't
compare you damn i said you were acting
like him you're exactly like your mother
everything you're complaining about her
you're doing you're suffocating henry
first of all i i love my mother she was
a wonderful mother just repeating what
you told me secondly how dare you
compare my mother into my mother i may
be like my father but i am not like my
mother you are
and you're like my father you're also
like my mother you're all the bad things
about all of these people but mostly
your mother when we would lie in bed
together sometimes i would look at you
and see her and just feel so gross this
certified fresh heartbreaker definitely
struck a chord with critics too with a
consensus that the powerfully acted
marriage story is among noah bombach's
best works and tv guides jordan hoffman
oso perfectly stated that while the
movie is 136 minutes the recovery period
is well at least the rest of the night
okay who's ready for a breakup i'm
kidding friends that is our list of the
best breakup movies to laugh and to cry
to hopefully viewing these can either
help you through a rough moment in love
or help you look back on previous
heartbreak with better appreciation in
the very least you're gonna laugh and
cry and we all need both of those things
every once in a while and if you have
nowhere to go this valentine's day
season i actually founded a support
group called heartbroken anonymous where
you can come and listen and share
stories of heartbreak to remind yourself
you are not alone thank you guys so much
for checking out rt essentials i am nas
perez and remember i heart you
[Music]